a genuinely stupid
happy Friday
I sincerely hope you're excited for your
three-day weekend I know why I am
this is what I did last year
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
memories
so whenever a huge ugly story unfolds
the media has to do its thing and like
Brian stelter at a pie eating contest
they never seem to know when to quit so
you sold an AR-15 at the gun show and
kill people
it's natural after a tragedy I suppose
to report and Report it's necessary but
then what if there's not enough news to
do more reporting well then you repeat
it and repeat it again
it's like that cars for kids ad that
makes me want to puncture my eardrums
I know
they really are talented though
but it's everything but facts you call
in Talking Heads and experts for angles
and emotional testimony they are the
Hamburger Helper of news if you will
adding volume to the main course and
when the reporting runs dry which is
fast the speculation begins and like me
calling my pharmacist it's Relentless
it won't stop everyone tries to outdo
each other and by more perceptive than
you are you more emotionally affected
than me the news becomes as productive
as an argument with a meter maid the
speculation is then punctuated by dribs
and drabs of new info which hours later
turns out to be wrong there was an
officer confronting a shooter no there
wasn't the shooter killed himself no he
didn't the press used to say that if
your mother says she loves you you
should check it out first
now it's hey guess until you're right
meanwhile everyone turns into little
Columbo's experts in speculation but
little else but at least Colombo got it
right in the end but now it's was there
a delay in police action and if so why
should they have gone right in or wait
for others did they screw up
you know it's like we could make these
decisions easily suddenly we're experts
in tactics and say what we would have
done I know what I would have done hide
behind Tyrus
then uh
then I'd offer Geraldo as a trade
kidding Geraldo oh stop it stop it hey
at least it wasn't you he's a lovely man
lovely man but we play Monday Morning
Quarterback Monday through Friday and
then some I find it hypocritical for
media to criticize reaction time when
ours is always off it's just in the
opposite direction just like when we
watch videos of cops interacting with
unarmed suspects suddenly we became
experts in policing as though we went to
school for it but in reality the closest
we've come to studying the police is
watching a documentary on sting
[Applause]
away Homer yes the fact is a lot of us
got journalism degrees to avoid doing
math
but we can't help ourselves it's the
nature of the beast when I was a kid we
had 30 to 60 Minutes of news tops each
day hell that included Sports weather
and 10 minutes of birthday shout outs to
people who went to high school with God
but now it's 24 7. we went from a little
bucket of news to an Olympic-sized pool
that needs filling every day it's like
tyrus's bathtub
whereas rubber ducky is an actual
Tugboat you got one more I know we got
one more it's two
but
[Applause]
but me pointing this out doesn't mean
it's going to change I mean I'm a
powerful Cog in this machine we call the
media but I don't have that kind of
influence I can barely get cat to bathe
I shower I shower twice a day yes no you
didn't but at least we should
acknowledge our role in this right now
we just show up at the end of a crime
but that crime is often the end of a
long ugly Road featuring clues that make
us wonder why we didn't see it coming
it's like terrorism you see how you
could have prevented it after it's
already occurred the problem is the bad
guys watch TV news too so the next time
they'll do it differently and we'll have
to learn another lesson again on how to
prevent that specific crime but you see
learning on the job is one thing if
you're stocking shelves at Walmart
but when it comes to policing learning
from mistakes usually means learning
from horrific human tragedy may be the
death of one of their own
so maybe we so-called media experts
should slow down our reaction time about
a subject we really know nothing about
and learn to do our jobs right first
before we worry about how others do
theirs
of course single variable thinkers will
scream guns after an atrocity like this
but we can handle more than one thought
there's mental instability family
disarray bullying a disturbing presence
on social media the ingredients in these
tragedies are as consistent as the ones
in a Big Mac
yes there are variables we should catch
early one of them though is us the media
we never lower the heat to these things
even though we know they trigger
copycats who see the attention as a
chance for infamy and immortality now
I'm not saying you shouldn't report
these stories reporting is one thing but
acting as a publicist for the Killer is
another the media almost turns the story
into a late night infomercial telling
young mentally unstable men who might be
watching that you too can be a household
name you too can go out in a blaze of
glory and make history you too could be
the next creep Who Shall Not Be Named
that's the reason someone chooses
suicide plus over just suicide suicide
plus has a payoff provided by you know
who us so as we criticize cops and say
they should have done it better and hope
they learn from it we should also say
that about the Press
too bad we won't listen
let's welcome
tonight
[Applause]
in Oxford prove he's terrible at sports
novelist and literary critic Walter Kerr
she shakes more foundations than the San
Andreas fault folks Fox Business anchor
what's wrong with me Dagan McDowell
her family's planning a road trip to get
away from her Fox's contributor captive
and his chest x-rays have to be shown at
the local Drive-In my massive sidekick
at the NWA World Television Champion
Tyrus
Walter good to see you as always thank
you so how do you improve an industry
like this in which our job is to fill
space it's not necessarily our fault
it's just that we increase the space
like 12-fold and now we're like just
stuck just going over the same path over
and over again there's a question in
there somewhere Walter by the way you
look great thank you man that's right
let's I think we can agree that he looks
great yeah he does thank you Kat yeah
laughs
well you know let's add to the problem
by having me comment on them
what do you think about the things that
I'm saying you shouldn't be commenting
on
um I I act I promise to try to be funny
later in the show yeah but I covered a
mass shooting once for a magazine in
Aurora Colorado right the midnight
shooting at a Batman premiere and I was
there in the morning there was still
blood in the parking lot there was still
Spilled Popcorn from the fleeting people
and the kids of the Town whose friends
had died the night before were sitting
around
looking at this police taped area
and one of them had a shirt on that said
My Bloody Valentine and it had a picture
of a head exploding
and I said that's a little strange to
wear that shirt uh after this terrible
shooting and he said whoa It's a band I
hadn't noticed yeah it is a band it's a
great band well so the moral of this
story is that I don't think we notice
anymore that we're absolutely saturated
in this violence in this talk of
shootings and Shooters we use the
language as though we've all you know
gone to the police academy yes um and
and my feeling after that shooting was
that
the coverage is like a blanket that we
throw over a body we can't we can't
stand to look it in the eye and so we
cover it in coverage one thing about
guns is that I think we can all agree
they shouldn't be in the hands of insane
people right
um but the problem is we can't Define
insane anymore
um and I I think that we could start
with ourselves we're a little insane and
we drive everybody else insane in the
media and uh
that's true yeah that's true Dagan what
are your thoughts on my eloquent
monologue that will win Awards
as a journalist yes
I'm doing God's work right because in
the last two years I have been your
virologist epidemiologist Economist
lawyer I've been historian on uh Eastern
Europe Asia and the former Soviet Union
I've been a petroleum engineer a
military tactician a weapons specialist
a beautician and when asked Walter if
you want to look better than you do
right now an amateur dermatologist and
plastic surgeon
oh but real quick
nothing has changed except the
saturation yeah because when I told my
father I called him on the phone when I
got my first job I said Daddy I'm going
to be a journalist and his response was
oh honey you're really scraping the
bottom of the barrel
couldn't you he was like couldn't you be
an IRS agent or like a Repo Man so it
hadn't really changed that's great uh
it's so funny we all have become experts
we all be it's even true in magazine
journalism you get if you wrote an
article in 19 like 83 on like Airlines
you will end up getting called by a
cable station citing you as an expert
yes all it takes is one article cat
makes you an expert in a lot of things
yeah well okay so I actually disagree
with some I think it's okay for
um to be critical of the police right
even though I couldn't do their jobs
because part of the reason that I don't
do that job is that I know I couldn't do
it so the people who do have that job I
think that they should be investigated
and if you know these were these massive
mistakes were made this way that they
are talking about people should be held
accountable I agree and I think that
that's fine to say what starts to bother
me is when there is all of this time to
talk about the story and everybody wants
to sort a hot take out each other right
where it's like someone calls it
horrible and then someone else says no
no no no it was unfathomable and then it
just becomes like a vocabulary Showdown
right it's like yes what are we doing
here yeah yeah yeah yeah like obviously
the families aren't watching these shows
right now they're like you know but it's
like I'm always trying to think like
what if they accidentally did how would
they feel seeing their kids up there on
TV how would they feel about seeing
their kids up there while they have a
picture of the killer which has happened
on like you know in in certain
newspapers they'll have the guy all over
the place and it's like I don't do the
parents even want to see that anyway
that's not a question I just want to
hand it over to you Tyrus for the final
thought well first of all you again you
said it right the other day sometimes we
just need to shut the hell up yeah
um of course mistakes were made he was
able to get into school and kill
children and two teachers and the people
who made those mistakes are gonna have
to live with that for the rest of their
life the teacher who left the door open
is paying for that the two police
officers were shot off the cops were
trying to figure out what was happening
in real time
every second that they're trying to
figure out a gun bullets going off a
guns bullet going off and then you see
people sitting in chairs like this
telling them what they did wrong how
dare you yeah mistakes were made
officers have to live with that one of
the officers lost his own child you
don't think he's got that's not going to
live with him yeah mistakes were made of
course they were but let's not forget
who's responsible
the murderer is he had time to plan he
had support he had Finance he watched he
waited he had the advantage and it's a
simple thing and I'm not a genius and I
don't pretend to be one but I'm a parent
and I was a bodyguard and my job was to
keep snoops safe I always planned for a
problem and it goes to Mr Kern's point
until you start looking in the mirror
and start saying that we have bad people
we have evil people we have monsters in
every town and every city and we need to
plan accordingly then we can do that but
until then we'll have round tables like
this and all these Geniuses on TV and I
go back to your awesome point and you
had the balls to say it sometimes we
need to shut the hell up
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else